maybe they could release
um marco rubio's dignity um i mean that
would be a thing that they could
probably well you have to find it first
well it's probably in a box down there
at mar-a-lago i'm just saying
um you know this [ __ ] guy did you see
this video of him talking about this
what an idiot who the hell is he trying
to fool here who are these manga
fascists trying to fool this is the same
guy i don't know if you watched some
videos this last weekend to marco rubio
and lindsey graham and some of these
others ran ball be like he's a con
artist he's the biggest danger to our
democracy
yeah well when they were when they were
acknowledging the risk right right i'm
having this before this is when they
were all running for president right
well they're all like we need to say
something that separates ourselves from
him and though you know they everything
they said was true
right as soon as he got the nomination
they got down on their knees and they
put their cheeto desk knee pads on huh
yeah they got ready and they said oh
yeah no this this guy's great he's great
he's gonna be a great president yeah
he knows how to unite
never divisive
doesn't run on hate does not run on a
platform of hate and xenophobia he's
great
right
okay marco little marco
um there's another video marco out there
really trying his best not to talk about
taking away uh women's bodily autonomy
in florida because there is one there's
one crazy thing about florida as crazy
as you think it is they are not they are
not for taking women's bodily autonomy
away majority of people in florida even
if they vote fascist they don't like
having their bodily autonomy at risk um
and marco rubio and
and ron desantis are really trying hard
not to talk about abortion so there's
that clip too but this clip here is
specifically about the boxes of top
secret documents that the cheeto dust
mobster stole from us and stole from our
government and has probably either
destroyed them or sold them to somebody
he thinks it's a storage issue
um let's listen and i'll rip his ass
apart it's really at its core a storage
argument that they're making right
they're arguing there are documents
there
they don't deny that he should have
access to those documents but they
denies that they were not properly
stored
i don't think a fight over storage of
documents
is worthy of what they've done okay now
this is all [ __ ] nonsense
okay and i said it in the first half an
hour this is all [ __ ] nonsense here's
why
here's why he is not he is not allowed
to have those documents that is all
[ __ ] yeah what what the government
is saying is those he is holding those
documents in a place that they should
not be
right
this is not an issue of storage this is
an issue of criminality of holding these
documents
unsecurely yeah and possibly giving them
away destroying them and committing
espionage